assurer bien la tête de lecture de trois
garçons écoute moi bien mon petit
bonhomme je sais que j'ai tué mon phone
tu réalises que tu comporte comme une
gamine je me comporter en adulte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma maman c'est mieux soleil ma maman est
douce maman est belle mais ma maman
pense que je peux pas me défendre tout
seul mais le massacre à leur tour devant
toi ma porte a travaillé bien mais je le
crois pas hugo je t'ai vu voler le
goûter mon fils de soie il peut pas se
défendre tout seul votre jeton
je confirme arthur et bien la tête de
turc de trois garçons jouer
faire ce petit morveux
écoute moi bien mon petit bonhomme je
sais à qui tu es
coutu et qu'est ce que tu fais bouffonne
va passer la guerre qu'ils veulent à
s'écouter vue il a piraté mon compte
comment ils ont trouvé ça non p6 google
tout est mon dd quick tu réalises que tu
comprends comme une gamine panis te
parles tu restes tu me comporter en
adulte cook
[Musique]
m
il a fait un bon quintal on pense à ton
côté tu verras tu à tarte et délicieuse
tu le rates adapter le technicien
mais de quoi je me mêle on l'a cru
[Musique]